お願いします 今日はあの
まあ一応希望というのはどういうものですかというテーマでお話しさせていただきます
で あの前の紹介で この希望っていうのは悪いものだとおっしゃられましたけど
二つの言葉を考えてはいけません
考えなくてはならないんですね
希望と欲望 で まあその二つの大体まあ日本語ではありますけど
あまり英語の言葉なんかは頭に思い浮かびませんですけどね
うーん まあ英語で言えばまあアンビションという言葉がございますね
アンビションという言葉は悪い意味でもいい意味でも使います
アンビシャスといえば
まあ時々英語だったらこの脈絡においてすごく悪いという意味でもあります
で またまあ頑張っているという意味でも使っているんです
だからアンビションという言葉にも意味が 2つあるんです
正反対の意味 また まあインスピレーションとかね
アスピレーションとかね
ホープとかね そういう言葉がございますけど
それ一つもあまり悪い意味では使ってないんですね
ホープレスという言葉は皆様知ってるんですね
ホープレスというと あまり英語だったらあまりまあいい意味じゃないんですね
ですから ホープといえばまあいい言葉で
で まあアスピレーションという英語の単語がございましてね
アスピレーションというのはすごくいい意味で使っているんですね
皆様英語で考える方々ではないんだから
まあそこら辺で置いておいて
日本語になると言葉 2つあるんですね
希望と欲望 で もうご存知でしょうね
欲望は日本語でもあまりよくないんですね
で 希望はよくないとはあまり気に誰も言わないんですね
ですから その線路で考えてみましょう
で  2種類あるんだと 悪い希望と
いわゆる欲望 あってほしい考え方は希望と
その 2つに分けて考えてみましょう
じゃあ欲望というのは何でしょうかと
で 文字通りに  それは日本語の言葉なんですけど
文字通りに まあ欲に基づいて何か希望することを
願望することは欲望なんですね
それで欲に基づいているんだから
まあ仏教の道徳的な立場から申し上げると
あまりいいものだとは言えません
で 欲はいろいろありますけど
で 一番この病的な欲望がございまして
それはパーリ語でアビッジャーというんですね
アビッジャーというのです
で あ これはないですね
で これは日本語訳すると
あの 今日はちょっと調べなかったんだけど
欲望として理解すればよろしいのです
その言葉を分析してみると
あの こういう言葉 2つ
アビとイッチャーという言葉からできているのです
アビというのはいつでもこのレベルを超えているという意味なんですね
普通の常識的なレベルをまあ飛んでいると
イッチャーっていうのは希望
欲しがるもの 欲しいと思うこと
ですから レベルを超えて欲しがる
普通の状態をの超えて欲しがることをアビッジャーと呼ぶんですね
そのアビッジャーというのは仏教でこの十悪
罪を種類に分けているんです
あの聖書の十戒とは似てないんだけど
まあとにかく悪は種類ですと
その中で一番力強い悪行
つあります そのつの中でにこれ入るんですね
その種類の悪業の中で 1番目に出てくるのは殺生
2番目に出てくるのは盗むこと
で  3番目に出てくるのは
よこしまな行為  4番目に出てくるのは嘘を言うこと
それから 5番目は 人を厳しい言葉で叱ること
人をけなしたり叱ったりすること
いわゆるもう悪い言葉を使って人の心を傷つくこと
で  6番目でしたっけ？ 6番目に出てくるのは
あの噂 人の平和な生き方を壊すために噂を言うこと
次にあるのは あの無駄話
時間を無駄にする 頭の知識をもう何といいますか
無駄に使う 無駄話 無駄話すると頭がもう悪くなっちゃうんです
それはまあ次にあるのは
アビッジャー  8番 アビッジャーの方が罪は重いんです
9番目はヴェーパーデといって
あの真にすごい怒り その場合は本当の怒りを見せているんです
10番目はこの邪見と書いてあって
この考え方は間違っていると
そのリストの 10番目は一番重い罪で
だから最後の 3つは罪が重いんです
そういうわけで この欲望っていうのはかなり重い罪として
悪行として理解した方がいいんです
はい で 私はアビッジャーは簡単な日本語で
まあ余計な欲と解釈 解釈するんですね
余計な欲 余計なという余計という言葉を付けているのは
一般の人々には欲があるんです
で そこは余計とは言えません
普通の日常生活の中にある欲は
で それよりもっとちょっともう次元というか
この制限を破られて もうキリがなく欲が出てくると
それ余計な欲というんです
ですから 一般的な欲は
まあそれは修行しない限りは
まあどう んですね でも修行とか何とか仏教とか何とかする以前
この余計な欲を抑えなくちゃいけないんです
この十悪というものが
まあそれは仏教徒であろうか
そうでなかろうか 人間誰でも気をつけなくちゃいけない
起こす 犯したら罪になるんです
罪っていうのはまあ宗教に関係ないものなんです
善と悪というのは宗教と関係なく普遍的な法則なんです
ですから この十悪っていうのは
仏教徒はやってはいけない戒律ではないんです
生命が誰でも犯したら罪を犯していることになると
殺生も同じことで 盗むことも同じことで
盗むことは仏教徒は盗んだら罪を犯すんだとか
他の人を盗んだら構いませんということはないんです
それはどんな宗教の人であろうとも
宗教でない人であろうとも
盗んだらそれはいけないことで
動物の世界の中でも やっぱり他人のものを盗んではいけないんです
でも盗む動物はいますけどね
そういうわけで この余計な欲っていうのは
我々人類みんな抑えなくちゃいけないことなんです
その欲望はもう何も問題なし
もう悪いものなんですね
ですから 欲望を捨てなくちゃいけないんです
それにつなげて またパーリ語で
この欲望についてまたいろいろ専門用語が用語がございます
マヒッチャターという言葉がございます
それはこういうふうな言葉から成り立つのです
マハーとイッチャ イッチャー
イッチャーは前にも書きましたから
マハーっていうのは大
大きいという イッチャーっていうのは希望ですね
まあ希望と言ったっても
これ悪い意味で使っているですから
欲望なんですね あまりにも大きい希望という大きい欲望
で マヒッチャターっていうのは
お釈迦様はものすごく戒めているんです
切りがない 欲はもうとんでもない
特に出家している人 お坊さんたちにはもうものすごい厳しく
マヒッチャターはやめなさいと
何にもなりませんと 罪だと言っております
それからもう一つ 専門用語がここ書かれます
これはパーピッチャターと読むんです
まあ大体似ている言葉なんですね
パーピッチャター パーピッチャターっていうのはこういう風に成り立つのです
パーパ それからイッチャ
イッチャタになります
パーパイッチャター まあいくらかパーリ語の勉強になりますからね
まあイッチャターっていうのはまあ恋しがるということで
パーパっていうのはもう罪という意味なんですね
悪という意味なんですね
ですから 悪とプラス恋しがること
だから日本語でどういう訳はよろしいでしょうかね
まあこちらイッチャーと書きましたけど
まあ私はちょっと間違ったんじゃなくて
イッチャーという言葉があります
パーリ語って結構ややこしいんです
こういう単語もあります
イッチャターという単語もあります
マナーイッチャターっていうのは大
大きな 欲望 あんまり大きな巨大巨大欲
パーピッチャターっていうと
悪い欲望ですね 悪欲だな
そういうのは皆様 この仏教経典なんか調べると出てくる言葉で
欲望に関わる言葉なんですね
全部お釈迦様は良くないときちんと明確に判断なさっている言葉なんです
じゃあそれで問題は この前書いた言葉
このアビジャ 今書いている言葉はマヒッチャタあるいはパーピッチャタ
なんで悪いですかということなんです
こういうふうに理解しなくちゃいけない
あまりにも欲望ある人の心の状態は何ですか？あれも欲しい
これも欲しい あれ ああいう風になりたい
こういう風になりたいとかね
そういうやりたい なりたい
欲しいという考え方ばっかり
心の中にある人の心にはものすごい大きな穴があるんですね
いわゆる空っぽというか
悪い意味で空っぽなんです
何もないんですね 満たされてないんですね
精神的に 精神的に満たされてない状態なんです
そこで前の言葉で言ったこのアビチャの場合は
穴あるのはいいんだけど
底がないんですね マヒッチャタの場合も底がない穴なんですね
ですから いくらものを入れても
あの穴穴を埋めることにはいけませんね
埋めないんです 欲望の特色はそういう特色なんですね
いくらあっても足らない
それは欲望なんですね
満足しない それで心には大きな穴ができちゃっている
そういうことは この欲望ある人は
簡単に言えばものすごく暗いんです
すごく暗いんです ネガティブなんです
明るくはない で 本当かないかと
皆様も私より社会の中で人々といろんな関係もできているんだから
その欲深い人々の顔なんか見てください
生き方とかね それすごい欲深い人の家なんか訪ねてみてください
ものすごく暗い影があることは見えるはずなんです
顔も暗いし 美しくないんです
そういうわけで このネガティブ思考なんですね
欲望っていうのは で ネガティブ思考で暗い心で行動している
そういう人々が行動して何をするんですかというと
破壊だけしか何もできないんです
この我々のシステムを
生きるシステムを破壊するんです
例えばお金に欲望があるとする
それはわかりやすい例なんですね
お金に欲望ある人はとにかくどんな方法でもいいんだから
手段を選ばないでお金が貯まる
貯まろうとしているんですね
手段のことを考えない
相手の気持ちは考えない
社会システムのことを考えない
社会の秩序やら平和な平和やら調和やら
そんなことはまるっきり構わない
自分にお金さえ入ればよろしいと
そうなるとどうなりますかね
社会のこの調和的な生き方は壊れちゃうんですね
ですから 一人の欲望の人でも社会にいることは社会自体に迷惑なんです
で かえってその人はお金いっぱい入ったんだからといって明るく行動するかというと
それもしない 足りません
足りませんという気持ちでいるんだから
そこでお金貯まるだけで流れていかないんですね
人の役に立たないんですね
社会の役に立たないんです
そういうわけで まあなんのことなく
最も簡単に考えると 欲望っていうのは純粋に悪いものなんです
欲望あるんだから成長しましたと
成功しましたということはあり得ないんです
だから人生失敗したければ
まあすごい欲望作れば簡単にできるんです
全部もう失敗していくんです
欲望ある人には 一時的には人の財産やらなんか奪うことはできるんだけど
それ一回限り それで終わりと
いくらでも社会を見ると例があるんですね
あまりにも 例えばお金に欲が出てきて
もうなんとか悪い工夫して悪い方法でお金を取ると
一回きりと終わっちゃう
それでその人の人生もそれで終わってしまっちゃうんです
幸福な生き方はそれで終わってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 幸福な生き方を目指す人は
欲望は毒だと 罪だと 大敵だと思わなくちゃいけないんですね
それは仏教を修行する以前にやらなくちゃいけないことで
ヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかやる以前
そういうことはもう覚悟して決めておかなくちゃいけないんです
基本的な道徳 すごく恐ろしいものなんです
で このそういうふうな
このマヒチャタという暗いエネルギーで物事を考える人々が
ものすごく暗いネガティブ思考を持ってるんだから
悪知恵ばっかり使ってるんだから
まあ社会に家族に会社に迷惑ばっかりかけたりして
それから自分の体も心も健康も全部損なってしまっちゃうんです
全部失うんです それに面白いジャータカ物語があるんです
ジャータカ物語っていうのは
まあちょっとした子供向きのストーリーなんですね
ですから ストーリーを言うんだからといって怒らないで
まあそれは子供向きの話なんですけど
ある国の王様がいて こう突然
マヒチャタ巨大な欲望が生まれたんです
なぜ生まれたんですかというと
隣の国のスパイが出てきて
王様へね あなたはね こんなにすごい王様なのに
こんなにすごいいい軍隊を持ってるのに
なんでこの小さい国を治めて満足しているんですかと
大王になればいいんじゃないかと
隣隣の国々はそれほど強くないんだと
攻めればいいんじゃないかと
こんな希望が小さくてよくないと言われたら
突然その王の頭の中に欲望が生まれたんです
欲望が生まれて よし わかった
隣の国を攻めて その国を私の国に繋げてみると言って
すぐもう軍隊を集めて戦いに出ようと出たんですね
そこでこの王様に指導する知識人のグループがいつでも昔いましたからね
その知識人の一番偉い人が全然賛成しないんですね
やめた方がいいんじゃないかと
隣と喧嘩するのは 戦争するのは
まあ落ち着いて平和でいればいいんじゃないかとずっと言ってるんですね
言ったら怒られるんですね
あなたみたいな このもう規模小さい小者が
私は大臣にしたんだから
私の立場も小さくてしょうがないんだと
かっこつけないんだと
ですから あなたの意見なんかは聞きませんと
言ったら でも その大臣の人が大変王様のことを心配するんですね
心配するんだから 軍隊と一緒にそれでも出かけたんです
出かけたところで 一部出て行ったところで森があって
そこら辺でみんなこのキャンプを作ったんですね
その日にちになってくると
インドのこの雨季が出てくる
王様は雨が降ったってもね
軍隊は逃げてはいけませんと
専心するべきですよとものすごく威張って言うんですね
そこでこの馬たちに食べるために
この豆の一種類の豆がありまして
それはよく煮たんですね
よく煮て すごい体力つける食べ物で
で 粒が大きいんです 豆といっても日本の豆とは形違いますけどね
まあちょっと四角い形なんです
売ってます 日本でも インドの料理なんか売っているところに行けばあります
で まあ結構人間も食べる美味しい食べ物ですけど
で まあ大きさはまあピーナッツの豆ぐらい大きいんですけど
で まあその豆を煮て まああっちこっちあっちこちたくさん作るんだからね
置いといたんですね そこで
木から猿が落ちてきて降りてきて
あ これ美味しい食べ物があるんだということで
この左手で握り一つ握っちゃったんですね
あれ 粒が大きいんだからなかなか握れません
とにかく握ったんです
でもまだたくさんなるんですね
そうすると右手にもまた握ったんですね
見たらまだたくさんあるんですね
それで口にも入れたんです
口にもいっぱい入れて
また両手で持ってまあ行くんです
行って まあこう登れるような木があって
そこに登ったんですね
でも両手はもう使えませんだから足でしか登れないんですね
それで登ったところで
手から豆がちょんと落ちたんですね
豆一つ落ちたら この猿がそれにキャーと泣いて
もうあの両手にあった豆も全部捨てて
急に急いで降りたんですね
で 降りた時は あの猿が持っていた豆は全部一つもない
口のものも落ちてるんです
で それからバラバラ落ちてるんだから
一つ一つつかまなくちゃいけないんですね
それを王様は見ていたんですね
見てて笑った あのバカな猿が一つ手で取って
それ食べればいいのに
欲深いなとかね 欲深くて全部なくなったんだと
言ったら あの小門のバラモン人も
まあ猿だけじゃないんだと
欲深いのは そこら辺もいるんじゃないかと
同じ猿と同じことやってる人が
だから何のことですかと
そしたら じゃああなたはどうですかと
王様はどうですかと 今
自分の国で十分満足しているのに
この雨季の時 隣の国を攻めようとしていて
このインドの雨季だから毎日雨が降るんです
それで象が風邪引いて熱を出して死んじゃうわ
馬が風邪引いて熱出して死んじゃうわ
人間もっと先に死んじゃう
隣の国に行くと もうみんな病気のもうもう人々で
簡単にみんな殺されるんだと
王様も簡単に首元から刺されて殺されるんだと
ですから もう猿よりひどいんじゃないかと
あなたやってることは
聞いたらまた目が覚めて
よし わかりましたと じゃあ帰りましょうと言って帰ったと
そのストーリーっていうのは
やっぱりこの多欲ですか
大きな欲望ができたら
持ってるものをなくなるんだっていう話なんです
持ってるものをなくなるんだと
で そういう昔話がなくても
この日本でもね 最近ね
結構偉い人々が逮捕されたりとかね
したでしょうに ほんのわずかなお金に欲を出すって
自分にはすごい誰よりも高い給料あるのに
それからもう会社やらね
まあ大蔵省からもう住んでる家は貸してあげるあげるし
車は運転手さん付きで貸してあるし
まあどこへ行っても外国へ行ったっても
ちゃんと国からね 航空券やらホテル代やら全部降りるし
お金かかるものは何もないんですね
奥さんの服代と子供たちの教育代だけなんですけど
それなのに もうちょっと裏でお金もらおうではないかと
どこかへ行ってもう食べようではないかと
そんな欲を出したところで
自分の立場もないし 仕事もないし
やがて逮捕までされちゃう
全部不本意になってしまっちゃうんです
ですから そういう欲望は良くないということは
まあ正真正銘の話なんですね
で あの わかりやすいことは
このわかりやすいことではなくて
我々理解してほしいことは
この欲望ある人は暗いということ
ネガティブ思考を持ってるということ
ですから 英語ではプロダクティブではないんです
プロダクティブって日本語で何と言いますかね
いわゆる効果的な有効的な人々じゃないんですね
ディストラクティブなんで
すべてに破壊して壊しちゃうんですね
そういうわけで まあ会社倒産したければ
まあ欲望を作ればとても簡単に倒産するんです
家庭を崩壊したければ
家の誰か一人でいいんです
すごい欲望を出しちゃえば
それでその家庭は崩壊する
国自体が崩壊したければ
国の権力を持ってる人々は欲望を出しちゃえばすぐ崩壊するんです
で まあちょっと何年前の例があるでしょうね
このイラクが結構力強くお金もあったのに
欲望を出しちゃって クウェートも取っても取ろうではないかと言って
力強い国だから まあ 1 日でクウェートという国を捕まったんです
それでどうなったんですかというと
今食べ物もないんですね
子供たちが死んでしまうんですね
病気で 食べ物が大量に
アメリカからこの劣化ウランの爆弾を落としちゃったんだから
みんな被爆して もうガンはみるみるうちに
あっちこっちみんなにもうガンが出てきて
今死ぬんです 当日に死ななかったんだけど
それから何年間 この人々は死んでいくかわからないんです
原子爆弾も片っ端から落とされ
ですから この私はこのアメリカとかね
他の国々がやったことも正しいとは
仏教男だから思ってはないんだけど
かえってイラクやったことは正しいと思う
けど それは全くそうでもないしね
イラクが欲望を出して
その国自体崩壊して みんな不幸にしてしまったんですね
それで最近のインドとパキスタンの問題を考えると
インドは威張るために原子爆弾を作ったんですね
で パキスタンも威張る実験したんですね
で パキスタンもインドやるんだったら我々もやるぞと思って
また核実験しましたし
そこでパキスタンには財産はないんです
インドほど 国は小さい
完全にヨーロッパにアメリカに依存していたんですね
いろいろ政治的な問題がありましたから
技術も それから収入資源もほとんど西洋依存ですね
それなのにインドに対して威張ってやろうではないかと
あれやって今パキスタンは大変なんです
この情報を読んだところで
パキスタンの何て言いますか
大蔵大臣がこのもうものすごい厳しい
今度はもう厳しい あれ
何といいますか このファイナンシャルリポートというものを毎年出しますからね
出すと それ出しても やっぱりもう大統領の意見は
まあこれでもこの国は立ち上がらないんだと
ですから 何のために欲望するんですかと
国自体崩壊するんです
そういうわけで まあ欲望というのは
まあもうあまり説法しなくても
悪いことだとは誰にでもわかると思います
その欲望の中で この私は訳しているような
この余計な欲なんですね
余計な欲だから 例えば家族を家族を楽にしてあげたい
ですから まあもうちょっと収入あれば
もうちょっといいところに住めるんだと
もっといい もっと美味しい食べ物を食べられるんだと
ぐらいの欲っていうのは小さい欲だから
崩壊するわけはないんです
ですから このリミット超えたら
もうどこまで行ったってもうキリがなくなっちゃうんですね
糸切れた凧のようになってしまっちゃうんですね
それにわけがあって 心っていうのはものすごいこの煩悩で溜まっていて
貪瞋痴 キリがなく 貪瞋痴に汚染されているんですね
私はよく言うのは 我々は歩く原子爆弾のようなものなんですね
一応貪瞋痴を我々はなんとかして抑えて抑えているんです
ちょっとでもなんかネジを緩んじゃったら
もう爆弾 原子爆弾爆発したような感じで
限りなく爆発してしまってひどい目に遭うんです
ですから お釈迦様の心理学的な立場から言うならば
無明にキリがない 欲にもキリがない
怒りにもキリがない どこまででも成長する
あれは原子爆弾に例えるのは
この全く原子爆弾と同じく
この連鎖反応でどんどんどんどん成長していくんです
例えば皆様方ね 夏休み
どこかに旅行しようとするでしょうし
で どこかに旅行したら
ああ良かった 満足ということじゃなくて
もっといいところに行けばいいんじゃないかなと思う場合もあるでしょうに
それで次の年 もっといいところに行ったら
その人が病気だからもっといいところに行かなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうにキリがなく
それを広げていっちゃうんですね
例えば食べ物に欲が出たら美味しいものを食べたいと
そこで自分で美味しいと思うものを食べてしまう
それで満足しなかったならば
もっと美味しいものを食べなくちゃいけないということになってしまっちゃうんです
そうするともっと美味しいものを食べる
さらに満足しないんだから
さらにもっと美味しいものを探し回ったりする
そうするとキリがなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで この欲っていうものは危ないもので
ちゃんと鎖でつなげて
あの虎みたいなもんなんですね
虎も飼っても構いませんだけど
別にどうったことないんだけど
虎を飼うならばちゃんとした強い鎖で虎を縛っておかないと自分を食べられるんです
飼ってるペットに猫だと勘違いしちゃったら悪い
よくないんですね だから我々はこの欲というのは
まあ猛獣の虎のようにのものなんですね
まあきちんと縛りでつけて
あるいは檻に入れておくならば
別に大した問題ないんですね
檻にいるんだからって
虎はかわいくてかわいくて
本当にいい猫みたいなペットですかというと
とんでもないんです ただ
檻にいるんだから危険はないと
それだけのことですから
この余計な欲っていうのは
我々を心の檻の中にいる欲という虎が
虎の檻を開けることなんですね
檻を開けちゃったらどうなるかわからない
本人を食べてしまうんです
飼ってる人は先に食べるんです
で たまたまこの象に人を殺されるんです
自分の国でもよく象を飼ってるんだから
だから象を飼っている場合は先に誰を殺すかというと
象は先に殺すのはこの象使いなんです
そばにいるんだから 象が腹が立っちゃったら
もう人間っていうのはもう何のこともないんだから
怒ったら先にその人を殺すんです
そういうわけで 余計な欲が生まれたら先に死ぬのは本人なんです
本人の人間の場合は 欲の場合は自分だけ死ぬんじゃなくて
周りの人々を巻き込まれてみんなを殺しちゃうんですね
そういうことで 欲望っていうのはよくない
また この欲望とは言いにくいんだけど
強い希望 願望生まれる
もう一つはあります あの
ヴィアーパーダというんですね
ヴィアーパーダというのは十悪の 9番目なんです
ですから すごく罪が重いんです
ヴィアーパーダという言葉はどのように出来上がりますかというと
ヴィという言葉にアーパーダという言葉なんですね
このヴィという言葉で何意味しますかというと
ものすごい変という意味なんですね
おかしいという意味なんですね
アーパーダっていうのは
相手を殺したくなる 害を与えたくなる気持ち
いわゆる暴力ですね 他人に対して暴力振るいたいと
他人を殺したいという気持ちなんですけど
それもまたヴィだから
ものすごく変に異常なんですね
異常に他人を壊したくなる気持ち
その両方もうこの前に言った言葉
あの   アビジャーという言葉前に言いましたね
アビジャーもヴィーパパードも
ある人々が精神的には病気なんですね
ですから 欲望ある人は仏教から見れば病気なんです
精神的に病気な人なんです
ノーマルな普通の人じゃないんです
このヴィーパパード生まれたら
異常な怒りが生まれたら
その人はまた病気なんですね
時々 まあ社会にそういう異常な怒りの人々を見つかるでしょうし
もうなんか子供たちでもね
まあ突然怒って他人を殺すとかね
そういうことはありますから
それはヴィーパパードなんですね
病気なんですね それは病気ですから
このヴィーパパードというのは怒りであって
普通の怒りじゃないんです
他人を殺したい 殺したい
破壊したい もうイライラしているんです
とにかく誰でもいいんだから殺してやりたいとか
それも出てきたら なんか欲望のように見えるんですね
それなんでそれ言ったんですかというと
この欲と怒りはセットなんです
正反対なんですが セットなんですね
例えば欲がある人はすごく怒るんです
例えばこの男女関係の中で
男の人はある女の人のことはもうものすごい
もう死ぬ思いで好きになったとする
それでなんとか訳があって裏切られたとか
振られたとか あるいはなんとかあって
お互いに別れたら別れなくなっちゃって
相手を殺しちゃうでしょうね
そういうふうな この人殺しはもうどんな社会でも見られるでしょ
旦那さんが夫殺したとかね
旦那さんが奥さん殺したとか
自殺になっちゃうんですね
旦那さんこと 私も頭がなんかおかしくなってる
で 時々奥さんは旦那さん殺したっていうこともあるし
なんであれほど好きな人を殺しちゃうんですかというと
あまりにも好きだから殺すんです
ですから 欲と怒りはセットなんです
欲ある人は必ず怒る 怒りっぽい人には必ずすごい欲があるんです
それを覚えておいてください
ですから ここで我々にわかることは
欲望ある人々が欲だけで危険だけではなくて
その裏で強力な怒りも繁殖しているんです
だからものすごい危ないと
あの人はまあ欲張りですけど
もう金にしか目がないんだけどね
まあいいんじゃないかと
大した害はないんだと
朝から晩まで金儲かることしか何も考えてないんだと言って
ほうっとするわけにはいきません
何やるかわからないんです
もしその人に金が入る道がなんとかなんとかで止まってしまっちゃったら
急に に怒り出す 怒り出しちゃうんです
怒り出してもうなんとかするんですね
で そういう風に汚職した後
お金を賄賂したんだとか発見したら自殺するでしょ
自殺するのは怒りなんです
なんかある国会議員の誰かの人がね
まあすごく怒って 自分が汚職したならば潔く申し訳ないと
それなりの罰を受けますよと言った方がかっこいいのに
すごく怒って自分で自殺するんですね
それで社会 日本の社会
日本の政治の世界が崩壊すると
あのバカどもが勝手に思っていたんだけど
何のこともないんです
名前さえ忘れちゃったんだけど
だから先に自分が殺すんです
虎と同じ そういうわけで
このすごい欲望が出てきちゃうと気をつけてください
我々の心の中で 人を殺すほど怒りも繁殖しているんです
で 今のこの子供たちもね
なんでカッとなるかというと
おそらくすごい欲望でいじめられていると思います
勉強しなくちゃいけないとか
あれしなくちゃいけない
これやらなくちゃいけないとかね
ああだこうだとか ありとあらゆる限りない欲で子供たちの心が病んで病んで
だから欲があると それは逆に怒りとして現れちゃう
それでカッとなっちゃう
ですから私たちはこの平和な社会を作る場合は
そういう心のこのからくり
よく理解しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうのは別に仏教と言ったってすごく合理的なものだから理解できるんです
欲と怒りは繋げているんだと
それは白いと黒いと同じ
光と暗闇と同じなんですね
光があるということは
光が消えたらそこは暗闇があるということなんですね
正反対なんですけど やっぱりセットなんですね
まあ仏教で厳しく戒めているのは
そういう風な病的な精神的な病的な欲望なんです
病気に至らないぐらいの欲望には
お釈迦様も別にそんなに厳しくは言ってないんです
ですから ものすごい頑丈な檻の中に虎を飼っているならば
間違ってでも自分がこの檻のドアを開けようとしないならば
別に心配する必要ないでしょ
東京のど真ん中に虎が飼っていても
上の動物園なんかいるんだから誰も心配しない
なぜならば 頑丈でちゃんと外へ出られないようにきちんと守っているんだから
心配する必要ないんです
ずっと近寄ってみることもできるんです
虎が昼休み 昼寝するところにガラスを張ってあって
だから虎はずーっと昼寝しているんだけど
こちらガラスだから そこから見る人々には見られるんですよ
それぐらい近く問題ないんです
ですから この欲は完全に消せ
完全に消せということは
一般的に一般の方々にお釈迦様が言ってるわけじゃないんです
それは出家者に修行する人に
悟りたい 解脱したいと思っている人々には
欲は完全に消さない限りは解脱はないと
心は完全に清らにならない限りは解脱はありえないと言っているだけのことなんです
どうしても虎を飼いたいと
ヘビを飼いたいと思うならば飼ってもいいんだけど
もう猛毒のヘビを首に巻いて飼ってはいけないんです
それだったら何かガラスのね
入れ物に何かに入れてちゃんと閉めて飼った方がいいんじゃないかと
餌あげる時でも気をつけて
ちょっとだけ開けて サッと餌をあげてすぐ閉めておくと
そうすると猛毒のコブラでも何のことなく飼えるんです
リミット外しちゃったらどうしようもないんです
それぐらいのことなんですね
じゃあこれ  それはこの希望の
希望じゃなくて欲望についての話
いわゆるこの良くない希望
仏教で否定している希望って何ですかっていう話はだいたいそこら辺で終わります
ちょっと 5分お休みしてそれでございます
はい 希望の話 で 欲望というのは悪ということを決めつけましたから
だから希望というものも当たり前で悪くないと良いということになるんですね
ですから これからいい方向に物事を考えてみましょう
希望はまあ いろいろパーリ専門用語はありますけど
思い出すたびに書きますが
まあ一応希望という言葉を使うと
日本語でも別に悪いことじゃないんです
いいことなんです 仏教は希望も否定していますかというと
全くそうじゃないんです
希望は否定してないんです
希望は一生懸命応援しているんです
希望であるならば で 皆様よくご存知
八正道の中に正精進という言葉があるんですね
これパーリ語でサンマーワーヤーハと読みます
サンマーワーヤーワーヤっていうのは精進すること
努力すること ただ正しく
正しく努力しましょうと
だから希望がなければ努力はありえないんですね
何のために努力するんだよ
何の希望もない人は努力しないんだから
ですから 希望がないということは怠けという言葉になるんですね
仏教にはものすごく嫌う言葉は怠けなんです
怠けること 怠ること ものすごい厳しく批判しているんです
お釈迦様はその怠けを批判すると
もう怠ける人々を人間扱いもしないんです
特にお釈迦様は厳しく批判するのは出家の人々ですから
出家者なんか怠けちゃったらもう人間扱いもしないんです
ある法華経で まあ怠け者は牛みたいに太るだけだと
何も知恵も何も成長しないんだと
食べて食べて 楽をして牛みたいにもう牛に例えるような人間扱いさえしてないんです
ですから 仏教では大変高価な高度な道徳的な立場っていうのは努力することなんですね
瞬間も怠けてはいけないと
日本語で言えば頑張りなさいということなんですね
ですから ただ単に頑張りなさいではなくて
サンマーワーヤーマ 正しくコントロールしながら頑張ってくださいと
そこでサンマーワーヤーマの中で正精進の中にあの 4つあります
項目が まあそれは大体道徳に関係ある
心に関係あるものなんですね
一つは自分の悪いところ
いけないところ とにかく直そうと
決してやろうではないかと
努力するんです 頑張るんです
そこでまあ悪いところといえば
何が悪いところですかね
お釈迦様が使っている言葉
アクサラという言葉で
アクサラっていうのは巧みでない
まあ下手な人っていう意味なんですね
上手じゃないという意味で
ですから まあそういう巧みでない
上手でない そういう性格何かあるならば
それは何とかして直さなくちゃいけない
それはまあ 在家から出家までいろんなランクがあるんですね
在家の方々にお釈迦様が言うのは
まず怠けることが それは悪いことやと
もう何といいますか 朝寝坊すること
早く起きないこと 在家の人は朝早く起きないと
その家は滅びるんだと
それからあまりも贅沢に陥ること
もしある家族 お釈迦様の言葉は直訳すると
もしある家族の奥さんが財産を握っているのは奥さんだから
特にインドの社会ではどうか分かりませんだけど
仏教の世界では お釈迦様は仏教徒の信者さんの場合は
財産の管理は奥さんに任せてくださいと
まあ男は仕事をして財産を生むだけであって
家に持ってきたら それはやっぱり奥さんが管理しなくちゃいけないんですね
家族は奥さんが主人だから
そこでもし家の主人たる奥さんがもう多欲で欲が深くて贅沢に陥っているならば
まあ崩壊するんだと なぜならば
男が外へ出て汗を流して儲かる財産は
全部自分の好みで 欲望で全部壊してしまっちゃうんだと
ですから この そういうふうなこのことは悪いこと
下手なことなんですね
上手じゃない生き方 そういうのはきちんと努力して戒めなくちゃいけない
朝寝坊したがるならば
やっぱり泣きながらでも朝早く起きなくちゃいけない
それにはもうどうしようもないんです
まあ徹夜で仕事したならば
別にそれはまあそちらに関係ないことなんですけど
一般的に言うと 夜は人を寝て
朝は起きて仕事をするんですね
ですから 朝早く起きればたくさん仕事ができるということなんです
特に日本は違いますけど
私たちのような南の方の国々になると
まあ朝 4時ぐらい  4時半ぐらいで起きると
かなり元気でいっぱい仕事ができるんです
10時  10時半になっちゃうとものすごく暑いんです
それで仕事のスピードはどんどんどんどん減っちゃうんです
そこでご飯食べたら 昼ご飯食べちゃったら
もう仕事を何もできない状態にもうもう疲れてるんです
それでほんのちょっと休んでまた始まるんです
それでまた 7時  8時まで仕事できるんです
労働をやっている人々でも
私もずっと見ていたんだから
みんな早く来て仕事を始まる
始めて昼間になっちゃうと
もうほとんどみんなあっちこっちいないんですね
あっちこっち休んでるんです
タバコを吸ったり いろんなことをしたり
それでまたもう 1時間ぐらい休んで
また始まるんですね 始まったらもう暗闇の中でも労働してるんです
それでさっと寝て また早く起きると
日本なんかはね もっとちょっと環境は違いますから
それなりに調整は認めますけど
やっぱり人はそういう自分持ってる怠けをなくすために努力することは
もう在家の人から出家者までずっと一貫してお釈迦様は厳密に言ってるんですね
それからお金の管理下手だったら
厳密に頑張って それを何とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
もし奥さんがそれはあまり上手じゃないならば
ついつい買ってしまう癖があるならば
お釈迦様の言葉からならば
その人からそれを外すってくださいの仕事
他の誰かが財布を握らなくちゃいけないんだ
そうでないと家は崩壊してしまっちゃうんですね
例えば伝統的には 例えば日本だったら
日本の文化では奥さんは財布を握っていると
だからといって奥さんと奥さんがちょっと精神的な弱くて
品物見たらつい買ってしまっちゃうと
そういうもうなんとか症候群ですか
そういう買い物をしたがっちゃう
そういう病気なんかなったら
もう早くもその人からお金を取り上げた方がいいんです
家族のために そのように我々持っているいろんな悪いとこ
見て見て見て それを直す努力
それは幸福になる道でもなりますね
だから人間にはもう終わりなく努力しなくちゃいけない
いっぱいあるんです 一つ弱いところを直しちゃうと
もう一つまたできちゃうんですね
隠れていてもう顔を出しちゃうんですね
それ直しちゃうともう一つ顔を出しちゃうんですね
そんな感じで 限りなく我々はもう努力して励んで
自分の悪いところを直さなくちゃいけない
それは 1番目なんです
その中の項目の 2番目は
今までやらなかった悪いこと
二度としない努力 世の中で破壊することをいっぱいあるんですね
例えば一度も麻薬を使ったことがないんだと
じゃあ一回だけどんな感じかとやってみようかと思う人もいるんですね
でも仏教では絶対やるなってやってはいけないんだと
あなたは今までやったことないんだから
これからも頑張って いくら誘惑されても頑張って守り
なんて言いますか 守り通しなさいと
その点で頑固になっても構いません
例えばタバコを吸ったことがないと
まあ別に一回だけ吸ってみてくださいと
別にもうタバコ吸わなくたってもいいんだからと言われても
私は一度も吸ったことがないんだから
絶対吸わないと 風に自分はやったことがない
悪いことに もうこれからもやらないように
ずっと自分を戒めなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 世の中は誘惑だらけなんですね
世の中見るでしょうに
我々は真面目にずっと仕事をしていた人々が
突然悪いことをしてしまっちゃう
突然 50歳になって浮気するとか
あるいは 50歳まで真面目に仕事をして
51歳になったところでなんかお金ちょっと取ったとかね
それで今までの成果は全部消えちゃうでしょう
例えばある まあまあ これ会社ではあまりないんだけどね
まああるところで まああまり言いにくいですからね
ちょっとごまかせますけど
まあみんな悪いことをしているんだと
それで若い人々が仕事に就いちゃったら
あまりこの気持ちないんだから
じっと自分が真面目に頑張ると
真面目に頑張ると なかなかお金たくさん入らないかもしれませんし
あっちこっちから 10万円に 10万
100万円の接待も入ってこないかもしれませんし
そうするとどんどん悔しくなっちゃうんですね
私もその人も同じ仕事をしているんだけど
その人は毎日まあ高級クラブとか
そういうところで 10万
20万円単位の接待を受けているんだと
私はそこら辺の飲み屋さんでまあ酒飲んでうちに帰るんだ
それですと悔しくなっちゃうんですね
それも誘惑なんですね
それで向こうの人はブランドのネクタイをはめて
ブランドの腕 時計をはめていると
それブランド製品だから
これまあ 20万  30万とかね
50万とか 100万とかね
それでその人は給料でしか生活していないんだから
2万円の時計しかはめてないし
同じ仕事をしていると誘惑されちゃうんです
なんで私は苦労しなくちゃいけないか
でもお釈迦様が言うのはやるなと
それでいいんだと あなたは今まで悪いことしなかったんだから
いくら誘惑されても頑張って苦労して
舌を噛んででも自分のポリシーを貫いてください
勇気を持ちなさい 間違ってでも悪いことをしてはいけない
それも努力なんですね
それで 3番目は 自分やってるいいことあるんですね
例えば仕事を真面目にするとかね
いろんないいことを人々はしているんですね
会社をもうちょっと発展してあげようではないかとか
そういう自分が正義を持ってやっているいいことをさらに完成するところまで続けなさい
あ これぐらいでいいんじゃないかといって
ほっとしてはいけないんだと
私はこういうこういうこと
私は朝 8時に会社に入って
毎日まあ 6時ぐらいまでは仕事をしているんだと
それでまあいいんじゃないかと
そういうふうにほっとするんじゃなくて
さらにさらにいいことないんですかと
毎日自分やっているいいこと
正しい生き方を完成するところまで毎日もう努力しなくちゃいけない
例えば学校の先生であるならば
まあ私は 5年間も教えてきたんだから
まあそこそこまあ今経験もあるし
もう教える内容ももう十分身についているし
でもう教え方も子供をコントロールする方法も知ってるし
まあそれぐらいでいいんじゃないかとほっとしてはいけないんですね
退職するその日まで よりフィットに仕事をしようではないか
努力すること それは仏教用語で言うのは
自分の善をさらに完成する努力と書いているんです
簡単にわかりやすく 自分の心にある善を完成する努力しなさいと
それが 3番目 そういうのはまあ希望につながる希望なんですね
それから 4番目は自分がやったことない
いいこと 勇気を出してやってみなさいと
学校の先生 たとえするならば
まあ今まで決まってる通りに教えてきましたと
自分の考え方を見れば
もうちょっと方向を変えて
子供たちを例えば外へ連れて行って
そこで授業をやった方がいいんじゃないかと
あるいはそのクラスの子供たちとみんなと一緒に
外国でもどこかへ行って
他の学校に一旦入ってみて
何かやってみたらどうですかとか
新しい考え方が生まれるかもしれません
いい計画 でもやったことがないんだから
やっぱりやったことがないんだからやめましょうという気持ちはすぐ弱気が出てくるんです
大体人間にそれやるんですね
いい考え方が浮かぶんだけど
やったことがないんだから
まあやめましょう それも仏教で認めないんです
やったことはないんだけど
いいことであるならば
勇気を持ってやりなさいと
いつでも先進 それも正正人なんですね
それで 4つで正正人は完成するんです
私も自分のお寺の自分の師匠の長老が亡くなった時の葬式で
式だりはもう遠い昔から決まってるんです
私は仏教の経典から見れば
まあくだらないことをいっぱいやるんですね
無意味な儀式とかね 私も一人で頭の中で
そういう無意味なものは全部カットしたいと
それは全部削除して 新しいお釈迦様に認められる新しいポイントを 1つとして入れたいと一人で考えているんですね
一人で考えてたんだけど
お寺だからもうたくさん村人と周りのいろんなお寺のお坊さんたち
みんな集めて判断するんだから
もう大変なことなんですね
一人の意見は全然通らないんです
でも私がこの考え方 新しいし
正しいし 自分から見ればとにかくやりたい
一番危ないのは この本山から長老が来るんですね
本山には全ての坊さんはすごい緊張するんです
本山から叱られたら大変だと
まずは何のことなく みんな集めて
この儀式式典の順番とかね
スケジュールとか 誰に何が与えるかとかね
どんな時間で何分でこれやりますかとかの話とか
みんないろいろ意見言ってて
全部意見 意見聞いてでまとめるんですね
最終意見としてまとめると
私はこの意見とこの意見とこの意見は同じポイントなんですけど
これ ３つやるとそれにも １時間ぐらいかかるんだからバカバカらしいでしょうと言ったら
やっぱり １時間はダメで
それは ５分で終わらなくちゃみんな言うんですね
そうするとこうしましょうと私は意見を言うんです
自分の意見  3つを取らない
取ってないんです そういう風に一度もやらなかった一つ式典に儀式を入れたんですね
入れたら そちらで長老たちがずっとどうかな
そんなことはやる習慣はないんですけどと言われた瞬間
僕はずっと経典といろんなところから引用して
なんでないと言うんですかと
あるんだと でもうまくいくわけじゃないんだと
まあとにかく入れますと言って
僕は全部そういう新しいものを入れて
まあなんのことなくそれ通っていったんですね
それ通ったところでみんなすごく喜ぶんでなあ
素晴らしく儀式がどこにもないように
すごくきれいに落ち着いて美しく終わりましたと
不肖らしい葬式でした
ですから このその時に私は考えたのは
このやっぱり新しい意見は正しいものであるならば
いくら伝統であろうとも
それは破ったっても構いません
破ってやってもよろしいと
それで中道的な智慧を持ってみんな反対しないように
みんなをきれいに押さえてもらって
じゃあこうしましょう
ですから 結局最後にもう本山から来た長老やあっちこっち方
政治家またもう来るし
もうたくさん来ましたからね
もう大臣 2  3人かあだこと
全部まとめて私が言った通りにもうやってもらったんですね
で あの それだけじゃなくて
いろんなことを私は新しい意見ができたら
なんとかしてそれを実行はするんですね
怖いと思わないし みんなやってないんだからという
全然そんなことには私はあまり認めないんですね
この若者 おしゃれするでしょ
僕はよく若者に言うのは
あなた方のおしゃれはけしからんと
なんでけしからん みんなやってることを同じことやってるでしょうと
それは面白くないんだと
例えばみんな金髪にすると
もう全国若者はみんな金髪
そんな感じなんですね
それは僕には面白くない
全く違うものをやってみたらどうですかと
そういう勇気はないですね
まあおしゃれは大した意味があるものじゃないんだけど
金髪するとみんな金髪
髪の毛伸ばすとみるみる人は伸ばして
同じ形で伸ばして ゴムバンドで締めて
男の男の人々が全く同じなんですね
あれで何が面白いんですかね
ただ単にみんなやってることをやってるだけだから
それだったらおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちと何の変わりもないんだから
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちも昔からやってきたものを
そんなものをやっているだけだから
若者は全然青春してないんですね
だからやるならば新しいことを
いくらか大胆なことをやっても
それは構いません その中で 4番目に言っているのは
今までやったことがない
いいこと 悪いことじゃないんです
今までやったことがない善行
を貫いて勇気を持ってやりなさい
ですから まあ会社で毎日同じことをやるということは
頑張っている人だと仏教から言わないんですね
ちゃんと時間に会社に行って
ちゃんと時間に退社して
家に戻って 決まっているパターンで行動して
それで歳までやっているんだと
あれは面白くないんです
仏教的じゃないんです
なんか自分で新しいものを考えて
いつでも新しくしなくちゃいけないんです
そうでないと生き延びないんです
死んじゃうんです だから何でもパターン化するんだから
日本のもいろいろ問題なんですね
何でもパターン化する
伝統化する 決まりにする
決まりにして 決まりだから決まりだからと
バカバカらしいでしょうね
決まりも決まっての誰かの人間だから
その人は完璧ではわけじゃないし
全知全能でもないし だから今の人は自分なりの決まり変えればよろしいし
そういう風に常にこの
何て言いますか プログレス
専心すること 前向きに行動することを正精進に 4番目に入るものなんです
ですから 仏教っていうのは結構勇気が必要し
インスピレーションが必要し
新しい意見 新しい方法
新しいやり方 ということは
常に考えなくちゃいけない
なぜ仏教はそういうことを言ってますかというと
仏教は無常論というものを教えているんだから
すべては無常であって
流れるんだ すべて流れていくんです
停止しているものは一つもないんですね
そういうところで 我々はいつでも止まろう止まろうとしているんです
会社を作ったら 何か品物を作るんだったら
全くそればっかり作りっぱなしで
それで毎日頑張ってるんだと
この毎日朝から晩まで頑張ること
残業をすることは 仏教から見ると全然頑張ってないんです
ずっと夜遅くまで残業しましたと
だから頑張ってるの 全然そうじゃないんです
ただ決まってることをやってるだけだから
そういうのは頑張ってることではないんです
ただ インスピレーションがないこと
いつでも残業することは別にもう威張ることじゃないんです
もし何か工夫をして残業にならないようにするならば
どうですかね そうすると電気代ぐらいでも自然破壊にならないんだからね
そうじゃないでしょ 大体会社に行く人々は残業あった方がよろしいと
残業手当が入るんだからと
仕事を長引けるんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
残業までして そうじゃなくて
とにかく何か工夫して残業にならないようにしましょうと
すると会社の収入は上がっちゃうんです
収入上がっちゃうと自分のボーナスが上がるでしょうに
特別に残業手当なくても
そういう風に この我々の人生は毎日毎日新しくしなくちゃいけない
それは会社だけじゃなくて
家族も同じことなんです
そこでこのサンマワーヤマって 4つを経典読んでも
私が言う意見はピンとこないと思いますけど
お釈迦様はの言葉で言うならば
行ってきた悪をやめる努力
やったことがない悪をこれからもやらない努力
自分が行っている善を完成する努力
行ったことがない善を行う努力と４つに分けているんですね
それは私は現代訳するんです
こういう風に 毎日昨日より良くなるように努力しなさいと
そういうことなんです
ですから 毎日頑張らなくちゃいけない
だから まあ昨日より今日はよく頑張りますと
あるいは今日よりは明日頑張りますと
というふうに自分を改善していく
成長させていく 発展させていくことなんです
だから仏教ではこの正精進には終わりがないんです
まあ解脱をしたら終わりなんですけど
解脱したっても 解脱した人々は怠けるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様は全部仕事終わったんだと
修行終わりましたと公言しましたけど
寝たのは 3時間ぐらいな 3
時間じゃなくて 1時間半
2時間ぐらいなんです
それも体がガッタガタ
疲れた時はお休みになっただけで
ずっと頑張ったんです
自分のためじゃないんです
社会のために 人のために
ですから 仏教ではもう死ぬ瞬間まで努力するんです
よりいい仕事をしようではないかと
よりたくさんの人々の役に立つことをしようではないか
そこでこの努力するのは希望なんですね
良くなりたいという希望でしょうし
でも正しい努力 間違った努力はもう罪になるんです
そういうわけで 仏教は希望っていうのは否定してないんです
否定してないどころか
修行して完成して悟り開いたっても
努力だけはやめません
比丘たちに言うのは いつでもお釈迦様は言うのは寝るなと
睡眠にふけるなと 徹夜してでも頑張りなさい
だから人間寝ることは自然的な行為であって
どうしようもないことなんですけど
それにまでお釈迦様ケチをつけるんですね
無駄な時間でしょうと
時間はもったいないんだと
こいつは寝てばっかしと
だから瞑想中でも居眠りしちゃったら
もしお釈迦様に見つかったらもう大変叱られるんです
だからそういう話を聞いて
あるお坊さんが昔の話ストーリーなんですけど
私は年取って出家したんだから
私には時間がないんだと
だから寝るのはもったいないんだと言って
行安居に入ったら 安居は 3ヶ月間
私は全然横になりませんと思って
歩く瞑想するは立ち禅するは座禅するは寝ることはしない
これで 1日2日は体持てますけど
3日4日になると体はもてませんし
それはちょっとやりすぎなんですけど
でもお釈迦様はやめなさいと言わなかったんです
努力しているんだから
そこで 1ヶ月間経つともう病気になるんですね
目がものすごく痛くなって
赤くなって 涙が出るわ出るわ止まらない
それでお医者さん来て薬あげるんですね
お医者さんもすごい真面目に
こういうお坊さんたちの病気なんかは
すぐ一発で治してあげなくちゃいけないんだと
ゆっくりゆっくり薬をあげたりするのは時間がないんだからといって
一番いい薬作ってあげたんです
あげても このお坊さんは座ったまんまで薬を目に入れるんです
それで薬は適当に目の中まで後ろまで入らないんです
病気治らない 言ったらお医者さんがまたお見舞いに来たらまた同じ状態だ
また薬あげる これあげてあげて
お医者さんはもう不備を認めて考えるんですね
私は一番いい薬あげたのに
この薬はこの病気には直接効くのに
なんでこの人に効かないんですか？と聞いたら
考えて あなたどういう風にどのように薬を入れるんですか？と言ったら
いえ まあただ座ったままでこうやって入れるんですよ
じゃないんだと 横になって薬入れ入れなさいと
はい わかりましたと言ってお坊さんは横にならない
それで見たら病気治らないんだから
お医者さんも怒ってやりきれないんだから
あなたにはあげた薬以上薬はないんだと
あんたは正しく薬は入れませんし
ですから私は治療をやめますと
で 帰っちゃった そしたらこのお坊さんが何考えたんですかというと
自分をさらに戒めるんですね
あなたのことはお医者さんからも見放されたと
誰もあなたの面倒を見てくれませんと
ですから 自分の解脱をすることにもっと励みなさいと思って
次の月も頑張ったんです
頑張って 3ヶ月とか回ると悟ってしまったんです
悟ったと同時に目が見えなくなったんです
両目も失明になったんです
で もうお釈迦様はその人は馬鹿者やと
やり過ぎやと否定してないんです
素晴らしいと とにかく頑張って自分の目的を達成しましたと
ですから 経典のストーリーとして
このモデルになる一人のお坊さんとして
その法華経のストーリーの中でこの 1 番目のストーリーなんです
それは ですから わかるでしょ？仏教はどれぐらい努力しなさいと言ってるんですかと
そこで目的なければ努力はないんですよ
だから目的があるということは希望なんです
そこで問題は 我々はどんな目的を作るべきかということなんです
そういうところで 仏教はちゃんと因果法則と道徳観と
もう自然の調和ということはすごく気をつけて
それは壊さないで 崩さないで目的を作らなくちゃいけない
いつでも我々は因果法則に基づいた目的を作らなくちゃいけない
人間間違うのはそういうところなんです
自分の目的を作る時はすぐ間違う
すぐ欲で目的を作る 怒りで目的を作る
嫉妬で目的を作る そうすると目的の初動は悪いんですね
そういう目的は良くないんですね
そこら辺はちょっと問題が起こるんです
人間には生きる時はちゃんとした目的はなくてはならないんです
そうでないと努力できないんです
ですから 私たちも努力するならば
希望するならば ちゃんとした目的を作るべきなんですね
そのちゃんとした目的っていうのは
一番肝心なポイントは実現できるかないかということ
英語で言えばプラクティカルかないかと
実行できるかないか 実現できるかないかということは計算しなくちゃいけない
ですから 実行できる目的
実現できる目的をまず 第1 ポイント
ポイントの第1 実行できない目的を作って自己破壊する必要はないんです
それから 世の中にある何でも自分にできるわけじゃないんです
やりたいことは人にはいっぱいあるんです
で 私にしたっても いくら日本語を喋ったっても
まあ英語で喋る時はもっと頭がもう活動するんですけど
楽なんですけど 英語で説法できればいいなと時々思ったりはするんだけど
やっぱり実現できないんですね
ですから 自分にしたっても
実現できない目的とかいろいろ作る必要はないんです
我々にも欲望を通して
夢を通していろんなくだらない目的が頭に浮かぶでしょ
ああいうのは捨てた方がいいんです
そういうのを捨ててしまって
実行できる 実現できる具体的な目的を作る
作って それを目指して徹底的に頑張る
それをもう得たところで
また次の目的を作ればよろしいのです
そこで目的を作る場合は
また仏教では決まりがあるんです
道徳的な目的を作らなくちゃいけない
この目的自体が ただ単なる
自分をやりたいんだからとかね
かっこいいんだからとかね
そんなまあけしからんなことで決めてはいけないんです
まず その目的は自分のためになるかな
自分のプラスになるかならないかと
それを決めなくちゃいけない
わかりやすく例を出すというならば
もう科学はまるっきり下手な人は
数学もあの生物学ももう何もできない人は
もうお医者さんになろうとかね
エンジニアになろうとかね
思わない方がいいんです
かっこいいかもしれませんよ
お医者さんもエンジニアも
でも自分にはかっこいいんだからやるぞと思ったら
自分のせっかくの勉強さえもできなくなっちゃうんです
科学よりも その人が文学系の今強いんだったら
文学系で頑張ればいいんです
文学系の勉強はまるっきりできない人が
歴史やら政治学やら そういうのはもう全くダメな人がもう
科学系統で頑張ればよろしいし
ただ単にこのかっこいいとかね
今流行ってるとかね 誰もやってるとかね
そんなことよくない 日本にこのサッカーですか？できた時はもうみんなの手にサッカーボールあるんですね
あれ見て僕はおかしくておかしくて
子供に聞けばみんなサッカーサッカー
でお子さんたちもまあすごい張り切っちゃって
自分の子供をサッカー選手にするぞとかね
いかに頭が悪いというと
人間っていうのは そんななりっこはないし
一部の人々がそれ足の強い人々がやればよろしいし
あれはただの人気やの
これは商売だからね スポーツっていうのは商売だから
急にこのマスコミで突然人気作るんですね
人間はもう何でも鵜呑みにするんだから
すぐマスコミの人気に引かれて
私の子供をサッカー選手にするぞとか
そう思ったっても 誰もサッカー選手になるわけじゃないし
それは稀な人間しかなれませんし
もっとサッカーの前にみんな野球
そんなものはもうすごくおかしいんですね
そうじゃなくて この人気で決めるとか
みんなやってるんだから決めるとか
そういう目的はバツ よくない
自分にできることを目的にすればいいんです
その個人に その子にぴったしできることは目的にすればいいんです
例えば ある子供がサッカーもできないし
野球もできないし でもそろばんがすごい上手ですと
それだったらそちら辺で専門家になればいいんです
別に 何でもプロになっちゃえば
それで名前があるんだからね
将棋でもね プロになっちゃえばすごい立場があるんだから
ですから 人間作るべき目的っていうのは
自分に実行できること
それからそれは自分のプラスになるかならないかと
それ考えなくてはいけない
それから次に 決して自分の目的は他人の迷惑になってはいけないんです
性学者になりたいと思ってね
まあみんなにうるさくて
大きな声で叫んだりすると
これみんなに迷惑なんですね
そこで私は性学勉強したいんだからとか言って
まあなんとかそれなりに
まあ他人に迷惑にならないように
自分の目的を達成していった方がいいんですね
ですから 例えば インドが核爆発を研究したいとかね
パキスタンもやりたいとかね
そういうのは良くない考え方なんですね
なぜかというと インドは私たちに技術がありますから
お金がありますからやるぞと
だからといってやるのは正しくないんです
なぜかというと 原子爆弾がああだこうだ作ったりすると人類に迷惑なんですね
そこでパキスタン インド両側がね
お互いにやり合ったりしちゃうと
中国をまたまた作ったりしたりすると
これ世界平和が壊れるんでしょうし
我々に必要なのはそうじゃなくて
地球から原子爆弾をなくすことなんですね
ですから できるんだからといってやるもんじゃないんです
技術はあるんだからってやるもんじゃないんです
インドの総理が言ったのは
原子爆弾は大国だと決める
決めつける基準だと だからインドは大国だと
中国には負けていられませんということは頭にあったんだけど
それは言ってないんです
だから大国だから原子爆弾はある必要ある
冗談じゃないと思いますけど
原子爆弾なくても大国は大国だから
その代わりにインドの経済的な状態開発すればよかったのに
他のことをやればよかったのにね
ですから 目的あるんだからといって
全部の目的いいわけじゃないんですね
他人に迷惑になる目的は一切やってはいけないんです
これ 会社にしたっても同じことなんで
自分の会社を発展しようと思って
社会の経済システムを壊してはいけませんし
例えば今 このゴミの問題あるでしょ
で それで自然破壊してるでしょうし
どういうことかというと
その各会社がとにかくものを作る
ものを作る 自分たちが作って売ることしか考えない
テレビで見たんだけど
膨大なパチンコ台 どこかでもう溜まって
一回火事になったそうで
全部捨てるんです 田舎に行って
膨大な量なんです あれ
どういうことかというと
もうパチンコやってるところでもう 3ヶ月使ったら新しい機械入れ替えちゃう
そこで作る会社も作るは作るは
作って取り外すものを全部持っていってどこかに捨てる
随分勝手でしょう そこで日本で一番金儲かる産業だと思ってみんな黙ってるんですね
そういうのを仏教では許可しないんです
何億万円の産業かもしれませんだけど
それですごい自然破壊なんですね
限りなくパチンコ台作るならば
誰かが責任を取って そのゴミ処理をしなくちゃいけないんですね
それは一般国民 なんで迷惑にならなくちゃいけないんですか？そういうふうに物は作る
作る 作る それで今何？ダイオキシンですか
ダイオキシンとかね それはこのビニール製品がああだこうだとか燃やしちゃうと出てくるでしょうに
簡単だ 楽だとかね 儲かるんだとか
それだけを思ってやるでしょうし
ですから ただ単に会社成長するためとお金儲かるんだからと言ってやるとすごい隙があるんですね
そこで土地の値段が強引に人工的に上がったでしょ
バブルの時は 毎日上がっちゃうんですね
今日は 1億 5,000 万と言ったら
じゃあ明日だったら じゃあ明日買いますと
まあ明日 1億 6,000万円と
そんな感じでしたでしょうし
僕はその当時で面白くて
毎日チラシ見るんです
この同じ家の値段が毎週値段が上がるんですね
一つの 1軒をずっと見張ってたんです
最初はまあ 1,000 万か 1,500万円ぐらいであって
2週間経った頃  2,000万円になって
上がるは上がるは 最後に 1億になったんです
同じ物件 2  3ヶ月間で誰も買ったことない
買ってないんだから ずっとお知らせ入ってるんだからね
随分勝手でしょうね そんなこと
それでそういうものは担保にして
銀行もお金貸したでしょうし
銀行の頭の悪い人々も
まあどうせ不動産の物価が上がるんだから大丈夫だ
大丈夫だと 大丈夫でしたかね
全部バブル崩壊したら銀行まで崩壊してしまったんだから
だからそういうところで人間の考え方おかしいんですね
ただ単に儲かるんだからって
それを目的にして お金貸し付けて貸し上げて全国民をダメにすると
それであまりもダメージが大きいんだから
いまだに立ち上がれない
いまだに円の値段は下がっているし
なかなかこの経済危機っていうのはね
立ち上がらないんです
で その影響は世界にまで広がっちゃう
だから 一人の何人かの頭の悪さっていうのは
世界人類にまで影響を与えるでしょうし
そういうのは誰一人も仏教を知らないんだからね
そういう正しい考え方あるとわからない
ただ 儲かればその目的に目指して頑張ればいいんじゃないかと
仏教はそんな単純に決めることは認めてないんですよ
私たちに目的があってもいいんだけど
その目的が社会に 世界に
人類に 自然に害を与えないことであるとちゃんと確かめなくちゃいけないんです
もしそういう商売であるならば
決して倒産しない なぜ会社が倒産するかというと
会社の人々の目的が間違ったか
あの会社はいらなかったか
どっちかなんです ある工場が倒産しましたというと
その工場の人々のやり方がまずかったか
あるいはその工場で作る品物は要らないものでしたか
どっちかでしょ だからほとんど要らないものを作っているんです
ですから 仏教でいうのは
もし工場を作るならば
その工場の製品が人類にどうしても必要なもの
なければ困るものを作ってくださいと
ですから 最低仏教徒の人々だけでも
自分が工場を作るならば
人間に必要なものを作ると
わざとこの なんて言いますか
この必要性をね 宣伝して作る必要はないんですよ
人間に必要なものを作れば
いくら経済状態が悪くなっても
必要な品物は誰でも買いますからね
倒産はしない ですから
仏教的に頑張ると倒産の恐れがないんです
そういうのは我々は 仏教は地球スケールで
人類スケールで物事を見ているんだからね
人間はそうは見ないんですね
自分だけの小さな範囲で物事を考えちゃうんですね
で 仏教でも小さな範囲で物事を考える立場もあるんです
その場合は個人なんですね
例えば 家族の奥さんが自分の子供たちと旦那さんとみんな幸せでいるようにというぐらいのスケールで考えると
それは決して悪いことじゃないんです
会社の一サラリーマンが自分がクビにならないように
リストラにならないように
ちゃんと会社に必要な人間になろうではないかと
新しい考え方を毎日やって
新しいことはどんどん取り入れて
もう自分の仕事を安全にすると
それは小さなスケールで
それは構いません でも
大きな会社 三菱も住友もソニーも
もうみんなそういう小さなスケールで考えちゃうと
人類は破壊しちゃう 国も我々の国だけ良ければいいんじゃないかと思ったら
その国は崩壊して破壊してしまっちゃう
ですから お釈迦様は おっしゃるのは
小さなスケールで感じられるのは個人であって
個人が自分には毎日の収入があれば
自分の家族を養う養ってもうちょっとプラスアルファでお金ちょっと残っているとかね
万が一の時使うためにとかね
それぐらいで個人が考えればよろしいと
もう体力は良くないんだと
欲望は良くないんだと
で 会社になると 大きな会社でサイバスになると
国になると やっぱり巨大なスケールで
地球スケールで物事を考えなくてはいけないんです
そういうふうなことで
我々は目的を作る 目的を作って
具体的な合理的な実行できる目的を作る
その目的を達成するために
昼も夜も努力するということは
仏教の希望の在り方なんです
で それは欲的な話ばっかり喋りましたけど
人間の一番悪いところっていうのは心なんですね
人間なぜ間違うかというと
心が悪いんだから 考え方まずいんだから
正しくないんだから ですから
常にどんな人でも 毎日自分の思考を直すこと
正しく物事を判断できるように
考えられるように それ心にある悪いネガティブ部分
怒り 嫉妬 むさぼり そういう怠け
そういう心のネガティブ思考ですか
ネガティブな感情をなくすために
このそれを目的にして努力しなくちゃいけない
それからもう一つ 個人に目的があるんですね
同じ目的なんですけど
より良い人間になろうではないか
より立派な人間になろうではないか
このままでいいとは思ってはいけないんです
ですから いつでも我々は不満でいいんです
私の今の状態は不満ですよと
もっともうほんの少々でもいいんだけど
もうほんの少々良くなろうではないかと
このほんの少々良くなったら
それでまた不安を感じて
もうちょっと良くなればいいんじゃないかと
ずっと不満を感じてほしいんです
仏教では不満を感じる人は良くなろうという努力をするんです
ですから 希望と一緒に不満という言葉があります
では 私たちは説法して何を言いますかというと
このいかに人間の不満不安をなくすかと
だからって不安 不満 悪いわけじゃないんです
不安 不満あるんだからこそ
人間が成長するんです
ですから そこにきちんとした希望というものがあるんです
希望って何ですかというと
今すでに私にある不満
不安をもう少しでもいいんだから
ステップバイステップでもいいんだからなくしていこうではないかと
それなくしていくと 最終的にすべての不安が消えて解脱のを体験できるんですね
ですから このみだらな無知的な満足感は認めていない
それは私はよく批判的な言葉で言うのは贅沢ボケという言葉
日本でよく見られるんですね
ああ 日本で生まれてよかったとかね
まあ生まれてきてよかったとか
まあよかったじゃなくて
ボケるんじゃないかと私は言うんですけどね
ああ よかったよかったと思うなと
それはボケだと 贅沢ボケだと
贅沢ボケだったらすごい落とし穴がそこにあるんだと
ああ それでよかった これでよかった
これでよかったとか ですから
このずっと不満 不満という
これパーリ語でドッカなんですけどね
我々は解脱するまで追ってくるんです
ドッカ苦しみ 不安があるんだからこそ
人間が前へ進むんです
だから仏教で徹底的に不満を理解しなさいと
ありとあらゆる側面で不満を理解しなさいと
なぜ理解しなさいと言うんですか？と
そうするとすごい希望が生まれてくるんです
その不満を何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから 仏教っていうのはものすごい徹底的に
希望っていうのは正当化して認めているんです
希望ない人間が怠けちゃうんです
ある経典でこういう風に書いているんですね
お坊さんたちに言うんですね
もしあるお坊さんが聞いたならば
なんとかなんとかの お寺に住んでいるなんとかお坊さんが悟り開いたと聞いたら
悔しくなってでも高慢になってでも頑張りなさいと
どういうことかというと
あの人にできたならば
なんで私にできないかと
あの人に努力できたならば
なんで私に努力できないかと
そういうのは本当は高慢なんですね
他人と比べ悪いんですけど
そういう気持ちさえでも持って頑張れと
良くなるために それは欲を持って欲を戒めるという言葉で言ってるんです
自分も悟りたいと欲を作るんです
それで隣のお坊さんが悟りしまっちゃったんですね
そうするとすごい悔しいんです
それで私もやるぞと すごい欲を使って
もうそれは希望になりますから
で 頑張りなさい そういうふうな
この正しい希望っていうのは
正しくコントロールした希望っていうのは
すべての生命の幸福につながる
希望は正しく持って徹底的に努力する人は
最終的に一切不満をなくして解脱まで得られる
だから解脱を得るために
人類の幸福 世俗的な幸福を否定してないんです
同じ道なんです 家庭の人が朝から晩まで必死になって頑張ると
経済的にも社会関係においてもどんどん豊かになっていくんです
頭はしっかりしようではないかと
思考をしっかりしようではないかと思う人は毎日勉強するんです
怠ける人は馬鹿野郎になってしまっちゃうんです
だから私は勉強しました
卒業しました 卒業証明書をもらったと
そこで終わる人は それからずっとバカになるでしょ
だから頂点はないんです
ずっと上へ上へ上へ行かなくちゃいけない
上に行くところがなくなったところが頂点なんです
もうそれ以上上がないんだと
そういうふうなことで
まあ限りない希望で努力するのは仏教の生き方なんです
じゃあそこら辺で話を終了させていただきます